The Emperor has long loomed over the Star
Wars saga.
Sometimes, he’s manipulated events from
the shadows.
Other times, he’s stepped onto the screen
and shocked audiences with his crazy powers.
From his days as an apprentice to his appearance
in Episode IX, here’s the entire Emperor
Palpatine story.
Sheev Palpatine, the man who would become
a Sith Lord and the galactic emperor, was
born on the planet Naboo.
According to the novel Darth Plagueis, young
Palpatine first discovered the temptation
of the Dark Side of the Force while collecting
Sith artifacts.
As a young man he met Plagueis.
The encounter led Palpatine to kill his entire
family and dedicate himself to becoming Darth
Plagueis' Sith apprentice.
As a result, Plagueis gave him the name of
Darth Sidious.
Like Plagueis before him, Sidious carefully
maintained his non-Sith identity as Sheev
Palpatine, and he became active in politics
on Naboo.
He rose in rank to become a senator after
secretly arranging the assassination of his
predecessor, representing Naboo in the Galactic
Senate.
He remained in that position for years, methodically
working to accumulate more power, gaining
strength both politically and in the Dark
Side.
While Palpatine gained popularity in the Senate,
Darth Sidious formed alliances in the darker
corners of the galaxy.
Appearing as a mysterious cloaked figure who
primarily communicated via hologram, he contacted
and manipulated groups who were dissatisfied
with the Republic, such as the Neimoidians
and their Trade Federation.
When it was finally time to make his bid to
become chancellor of the Republic, he encouraged
the Neimoidians to blockade Naboo, creating
a crisis that would provide him with a political
opportunity.
During this same period, Palpatine took custody
of a young Zabrak and had him raised in the
ways of the Dark Side.
The Zabrak became Sidious' first Sith apprentice,
Darth Maul.
Since nobody knew that he was the one behind
the Trade Federation's blockade of Naboo,
Palpatine was able to exploit the incident
to consolidate his political power.
When Chancellor Valorum failed to take strong
action to defend Naboo, Palpatine encouraged
Naboo's Queen Amidala to call for a vote of
no confidence in Valorum, which in turn led
to a new election.
Being the senator from the planet that was
in crisis, Palpatine was perfectly positioned
to win the election and become the new supreme
chancellor of the Republic.
Taking the top office in the galaxy was a
huge step in Palpatine's rise, but it would
still take years of simultaneously consolidating
his political power as chancellor while also
stoking the galaxy's conflicts as Darth Sidious
before he would be able to gain absolute power.
He would also need a new Sith apprentice,
as Darth Maul was defeated and seemingly killed
by Obi-Wan Kenobi as the Naboo crisis was
drawing to a close.
After the defeat of Darth Maul, Palpatine's
new Sith apprentice was the elderly aristocrat
Count Dooku, who acted as his proxy in leading
a separatist movement of multiple systems
that were dissatisfied with the Republic.
When the Separatists were found to be building
a vast droid army, Chancellor Palpatine was
granted special powers to deal with the threat.
As it turns out, using other proxies, he'd
already commissioned an army of clone troopers,
and his new powers enabled him to command
that army to go to war against the Separatists.
Not only was Palpatine's power increased,
but the Republic ended a long period of peace
to become a dominant military power in the
galaxy, a big step closer to becoming an empire.
Outwardly, the chancellor pretended to be
reluctant to take on the burden of greater
power and lead the Republic into war, but
of course, it was all part of the long game
he'd been playing since the beginning.
Three years later, Chancellor Palpatine arranged
his own capture by Count Dooku's Separatist
forces.
He was rescued, as he knew he would be, by
Obi-Wan Kenobi and Anakin Skywalker.
"I sense a trap.
Next move?
Spring the trap."
At Palpatine's urging, Anakin killed an already-defeated
and literally disarmed Dooku.
From then on, Palpatine began actively working
to seduce Anakin to the Dark Side of the Force
and make the powerful young Jedi into a new
Sith apprentice.
Anakin was concerned for the health of his
pregnant wife, Padmé, and Palpatine planted
the idea in Anakin's head that becoming powerful
in the Dark Side was the key to ensuring that
she survived the pregnancy.
Ultimately, of course, Palpatine didn't care
about Padmé at all, and it was Anakin's turn
to the Dark Side that led to her death.
In his new Sith persona as Darth Vader, Anakin
Skywalker would become the most powerful ally
Palpatine had ever had and a key part of his
plan to eliminate the Jedi and rule the galaxy.
When the Jedi finally realized that Palpatine
was a Sith Lord, it was far too late.
A vicious battle with Jedi Master Mace Windu
brought about a fearsome change to Palpatine's
physical appearance.
While there has been much speculation, it's
unclear whether Palpatine was disfigured by
Force lightning, as he claimed, or whether
he was revealing what had already been his
true appearance.
In any case, the evil within him came to the
surface, and his face got all gross and pasty.
Ironically, his disfigurement enabled him
to turn the Senate against the Jedi who'd
attacked him.
He took the opportunity to seize the power
he'd worked so long to bring within his grasp
and declared himself emperor of the galaxy.
Although the Galactic Senate would remain
in place for years to come, the Republic had
become the Empire, and with the Jedi eliminated
by the clone troopers, there was nobody left
to challenge Palpatine's power.
Almost 20 years later, Emperor Palpatine dissolved
the Galactic Senate permanently, because the
completion of the Death Star enabled him to
rule through fear.
Commanded by one of the Emperor's most trusted
and ruthless operatives, Grand Moff Tarkin,
the Death Star was a mobile space station
with the power to destroy entire planets.
As a demonstration of its power, Tarkin obliterated
the planet Alderaan, home to key members of
the Rebel Alliance who were working against
the Empire.
Leia Organa, adopted princess of Alderaan
and secretly the daughter of Anakin Skywalker,
was forced to watch the destruction of her
planet from the deck of the Death Star, where
she was being held prisoner at the time.
As these events unfolded Emperor Palpatine
remained unseen in the background, leaving
Tarkin and Darth Vader to do his dirty work
aboard the Death Star.
"I recognized your foul stench when I was
brought on board."
"Charming, to the last."
This turned to be particularly fortunate for
him because he was nowhere near the Death
Star when Luke Skywalker managed to blow it
up on behalf of the Rebel Alliance.
Darth Vader was able to escape the destruction,
but Tarkin and the other military leaders
on board all died.
Following the destruction of the Death Star,
Emperor Palpatine and Darth Vader both learned
the identity of Luke Skywalker, and they became
determined to find him.
As Vader searched for Luke and the Rebels,
Palpatine remained in the imperial capital
of Coruscant and communicated with Vader via
hologram.
Palpatine suspected that Vader wanted to turn
his son to the Dark Side and overthrow Palpatine
with his help.
Killing your master after you've found your
apprentice was Sith tradition, after all,
and it was exactly what Palpatine had done
to his own master.
For his part, Palpatine hoped that either
Luke would kill his father and then replace
him as the Emperor's apprentice, or that Luke
would die, thus eliminating the threat and
maintaining the status quo.
Eventually, Vader would confront Luke on Bespin,
but he failed to convert, capture, or kill
him.
He did however reveal himself as Luke's father,
ensuring that Luke would eventually seek out
Vader by choice, which could only put him
in the path of the Emperor.
With construction underway on the second Death
Star, Emperor Palpatine decided to take a
more active hand in the Galactic Civil War.
Arriving on the new Death Star to oversee
its completion himself, the Emperor carefully
laid a trap for the Rebel Alliance.
He knew they were planning to attack the Death
Star before it was finished, so he made sure
that when the Rebels arrived, the half-built
space station's weapon systems would be fully
operational.
What enabled the Rebels to ultimately win
the day was the efforts of a Rebel team on
the surface of the forest moon of Endor, where
the new Death Star was in orbit during its
construction.
Led by Han and Leia, these Rebels were eventually
able to shut down the shield generator that
protected the incomplete Death Star, enabling
Rebel ships to destroy it.
Ironically, Darth Vader had allowed the ship
holding the Rebel party to approach Endor,
even though he sensed Luke Skywalker's presence
among them.
That was the first of Vader's betrayals at
Endor that led to the Emperor's downfall,
but it was far from the last.
As the Emperor had predicted, Luke Skywalker
soon sought out Darth Vader on Endor.
The young Jedi surrendered, and Vader brought
him before Palpatine on the new Death Star.
The Emperor could sense that the emotional
Luke was veering closer to the Dark Side,
and he and Vader encouraged Luke to give himself
over to his emotional turmoil.
Palpatine seemed ready to die if it would
cement Luke's turn to the Dark Side, but he
was even more enthusiastic about the possibility
of Luke killing his father and taking Vader's
place by the Emperor's side.
Ultimately Luke resisted the Dark Side, casting
his weapon away.
At that point, Palpatine revealed that, like
the armed and operational Death Star, he wasn't
as weak and helpless as he seemed.
The Emperor blasted the young Skywalker with
Force lightning from his fingertips, preparing
to kill him even as the Death Star's weapons
killed Luke's allies.
At the last moment, however, Darth Vader was
unable to stand by and watch as the man who'd
ruined his life tried to murder his son as
well, and Vader grabbed Palpatine and hurled
him down a seemingly bottomless shaft within
the Death Star, killing the Emperor.
Darth Vader died immediately afterwards, and
Luke managed to escape just as his allies
finally destroyed the second Death Star, which
was a decisive victory against the Empire.
It's debatable, in the end, whether Palpatine
died on the Death Star or not, but if he did
he managed to come back pretty quickly.
He never exactly says how, but cloning seems
to be involved.
He hid for decades on the planet Exegol in
the Unknown Regions.
He created the figure of Snoke, the original
Supreme Leader of the First Order, to be his
puppet until it was time for the rebirth of
the Empire as the Final Order.
He also built an entire Sith empire on that
hidden planet, complete with a vast fleet
of Star Destroyers that would be able to crush
the Resistance and once again establish his
dominance over the Galaxy.
When he eventually revealed himself, he recruited
Supreme Leader Kylo Ren, who had already killed
Snoke and taken over the First Order.
Palpatine promised Ren even greater power
if Ren would fulfill his wishes, and for a
time Kylo seemed to agree.
Somewhere along the line, ol' pasty Palp had
himself a kid, and eventually his greatest
concern became his granddaughter, Rey.
He'd been searching for her since she was
born, but she was a grown woman before she
learned about her connection to him and journeyed
to Exegol to destroy her grandfather and end
his threat to the galaxy.
Then she learned that his death at her hands
was part of Palpatine's plan.
If she killed him in anger, she would turn
to the dark side, take the spirits of him
and the other Sith within her, and become
the new Empress.
When Kylo Ren, having turned away from the
dark side, arrived to help Rey, Palpatine
drew on both of their life forces to restore
himself, regaining mobility and his trademark
yellow eyes.
He used his vast power to shoot the Resistance
fleet out of the sky with those fancy force
fingers, until a weakened Rey managed to redirect
the lighting back onto him, basically making
Palpatine kill himself.
As for Emperor Palpatine, is he dead for real
now?
The Skywalker saga is supposed to be over,
so it's nice to believe he is.
But he might have just retreated to another
planet and another body, waiting for a future
decade to try it all again.
His ambition, after all, is stronger than
death.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.